i have the the privilege and honor to
represent some of the top companies and
and you know in in israel these are
companies that like you know they
started i remember a few years ago we
sent um yotpo for example uh we sent one
person to the us and and look where they
are now you know amazing um amazing like
you know you can't it's undeniable like
you can't how could you say that you
know a company like that hasn't
contributed to the economy in the us
creating jobs for for hundreds and
hundreds of employees and that's just
one example of of many of many
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright xl an immediate
partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders and where
today we're going to talk about
immigration laws the world is becoming
more globalized this is becoming a more
and more prevalent issue and today we're
going to learn from jennifer scheer the
founding partner of sheer immigration
law firm a boutique immigration firm in
tel aviv
s.i represents israeli and foreign
corporations ranging from startups
through publicly traded companies in
securing work authorization for key
personnel si works closely with local
high-tech accelerators and incubators in
the international venture capital
community with regard to corporate
immigration issues and compliance
strategies
[Music]
jennifer here welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm great how are you michael
thank you very very much for joining me
an expert in immigration law working
both in israel in the united states and
the intersection and the tech ecosystem
and and you know obviously we've we've
been seeing you know the integration of
the two
places coming together and we're seeing
multinational companies as well as
startups interchanging employees in both
sides and this idea of of this movement
is something that has really been you
know a cultivating piece of the startup
nation story and obviously there is this
whole complex situation behind it which
is the whole issue of immigration and
how do we actually deal with with a lot
of these people transitioning between
the two places and what does this
actually mean for the government what
does this mean for the for these people
these families these companies i'm
excited to understand this a little bit
better with you
but but before that jennifer tell me a
little bit about yourself and how do you
find yourself becoming an expert in
immigration law
um well just a quick background about uh
about myself um i grew up in cincinnati
ohio in a jewish community went to a
religious jewish school my whole life
and um of course you're always pushed to
go to israel for at least one year so i
came to do a year abroad program at
barilan university thinking i'm just
coming to do this uh this one year and
then i'm going back to the states but uh
as with many oleem or non intending or
lim uh i ended up i just ended up
staying here um so i kind of built my
whole professional this was many many
moons ago um
i finished my studies here i ended up uh
at a boutique very randomly being a
paralegal at a boutique a us immigration
firm where i worked for 10 years
uh after that i found myself at probably
one of israel's largest full-service
commercial firms establishing and
running the practice of u.s immigration
and then we just celebrated it here at
my my uh law firm uh sheer immigration
uh our fifth year anniversary so we're
boutique uh
that's how it happened
so what does this actually mean an
immigration firm well what is what does
this entail
okay so um you know we we are very very
very niche we do corporate immigrations
that basically means companies uh
primarily companies um that are
establishing a presence in the united
states and they need to get work visas
and and green cards for
um for founders and for key employees so
that's the the majority of our work we
also have a family based section and a
high net worth uh based private client
practice but i would say that about 90
percent of our clients are our tech
companies because those are the ones who
are you know they're getting their
investments they're setting up their
subsidiaries and then they need to it's
under the key people you know to make
the investors happy
right and so when you're working with
the companies and
maybe go back and tell me a little bit
about the complexity of why do we even
need an immigration firm and why do why
is this even a point of contestion that
you know that we need something you know
a legal figure to go and assist these
companies and all these operations
okay got it um so you know us
immigration um historically and now more
than ever has been very restrictive
um we you know they ever a lot of people
want to go to the united states um and i
feel like you know there's not a lot of
differentiation when it comes to you
know the high skilled people and the
low-skilled people and and and so on and
so forth so
in order to
keep it exclusive i guess you know the
rules need to be tight
so um you need a lawyer to really help
you strategize especially for tech
companies they're you know they're
starting with maybe
no employees in the united states
they're going on day one but their
primary market is the united states um
so there's a myriad of different types
of work visas some of them are more
popular than others for tech companies
um but it involves a process of like
building a petition saying why this
company is going to contribute to the
united states why we need this person
why they have the skills the background
the know-how how they're going to
contribute to the economy um and you
know telling you know basically
convincing the us immigration authority
um to let them in
um so that that's why really you need a
lawyer it's not something that that a
private individual could could do
themselves it's not like applying and
applying for it for a tourist visa which
of course you can do for yourselves it's
it's a process it's lengthy it's
document intensive um and you really
need a strategy in place for that above
and beyond the actual legal work itself
right now is this something that you
knew that you were going to be drawn to
from the get-go you know the specific
this type of law practice
um actually no it wasn't i originally
studied um i knew i wanted to go into
law but then i i originally studied
political science and history and even
despite my 12 years of jewish schooling
in the states um i wasn't ready back
then to go right into into law school in
israel um simply because everything was
was in hebrew um so i i finished the you
know my poli sci and i was like what am
i gonna do and i was working at this
high tech company in an admin position
and um a paralegal role opened up and
this is way back in the day we're
talking like 15 plus years ago now um
and i started working there within six
months i was like doing the attorney
work and they sent me to law school and
i i worked all through law school and
did the bar exams while i was at that
firm for for 10 years and that's how i
end up being
you know getting into this uh in this
field
um and so share with me a little bit
about what you've been observing in
terms of trends
you know whether it comes to immigration
or it comes to the integration of the
two countries what have you been
observing during your time
you know as an immigration law expert
sure
so um one thing i will say is that um
and i'll get to where we are right now
um
i wouldn't say it's post corona but sort
of semi post corona but um us
immigration law has never ever been a
walk in the park it's always been
difficult things got
really a lot more difficult the rules
and regulations after 9 11. there
started to be like just it just got
tighter and tighter and tighter and
tighter and that was across the board um
you know with with family-based
immigration and with corporate
immigration
um and so
um things have always been difficult so
now fast forward to to where we are now
um you know over the past you know 2020
was was a nightmare for us immigration
it was a great year for for tech
companies the investments came in and
you know it didn't stop and i thought it
would but i was wrong about that um they
just kept coming in and the companies
you know were getting acquired and so on
and so forth and and um but but corona
you know really we were dealing with
travel restrictions visa bans travel
bans so
this was putting an effective stop to us
immigration you know for for more than a
year and a half embassy closures so um
we saw a little bit of a shift um during
that period especially when the visa ban
was on when the main types of work visas
used by tech tech companies they were
they were you know they were shut down
completely for for a very long period of
time we saw a shift more people that
were let's say founders um that were
already in the us they were asking for
green cards like let's initiate a green
card process because we don't know what
the future is of us immigration there
might be still forever so there was that
um and the other thing was you know and
then there was the bigger question of
how do we get there even though we have
all these restrictions so our our firm
um we pretty much like learned how to be
like the experts on on the exceptions
because there were a list of exceptions
to any rule there's an exception um you
know how do we get around the embassy
closures how do we fit these people um
into these really really narrow
exceptions um and i think we managed to
to weather it that way so that was you
know until um the the beginning of the
new administration when biden came in
also you know trump's policies were also
very restrictive like on top of the
corona stuff um so when the chain we saw
the change of administration um
everything came back and big adult you
know like huge um more companies wanting
to relocate and quickly really really
really fast so i see over the past three
months um we've seen a really like a
stampede pretty much a stampede of tech
company saying we need to get there and
we needed to get there yesterday
that makes a lot of sense and so you
know how how how much variance is there
in in the work that you do is is it
traditionally a roughly the same process
for for the companies that are coming to
and you're repeating that process and
you're you're polishing it or is it is
it sort of on the case-by-case basis you
have to really form a strategy behind it
um it is on a case-by-case basis i mean
there are limited you have to we have to
start with the fact that there are a
limited number of work visa options for
um for israelis right
to start with okay so we're dealing with
like five six categories that we need to
fit um each each employee into one of
those categories and sometimes there are
no options like tech companies will come
to me sometimes pre-investment for
example okay they're like we're planning
on raising around and you know it's
going to be x y and z yep but we don't
have it yet we need to get there and i
say thank you i hope i'm not this
doesn't come as a surprise you guys
aren't ready yet okay but in a year from
now you are going to be ready and here's
what you need to do to be sure that you
hit the ground running okay once you get
that investment so you know there is a
strategy behind it um each case is
different there are nuances um i also
deal with um
someone you know gil dibner of angular
ventures so i'm an advisory uh partner
um on on gil's team for angular and um
we need to deal with with companies that
are not israeli companies we deal with
you know because gil invests in european
companies as well so we're dealing with
different particular challenges um that
have to do that are not not to do with
israelis you know for example there's
still a travel ban on from europe and
we're dealing with a number of european
companies we're still having to get
around that so i think the answer to the
question is is definitely not it's it's
you know we're dealing with a a certain
uh set amount of categories that that we
have to fit each person to but each case
is is different for sure
that makes a lot of sense now taking
this more to the side of the
entrepreneurs that are you know it's not
just multinationals that are that have
this consideration but i guess you know
today's startups that are raising f the
venture capital funding and they're they
have employees in both areas and they
need to start thinking
asking them themselves those questions
you know it's very confusing it's almost
like a black box you know dealing with
all this immigration stuff then
you know what what should i as a young
entrepreneur as i go about my journey
when should i be thinking about this
when when is the right time to go and
consult with an immigration
firm
how do i make sure that it's not
surprising me so that when i actually
need to do something about it then i'm
blocked and i have to now chase after
myself
okay so i think i mean the easy answer
is is as early as possible so you know
as an entrepreneur that you have a plan
and you know that your target market is
the united states and you know that the
chances are you can only you know rely
on consultants and remote control
management for a certain amount of time
and eventually you are going to need to
get there okay so and you're busy and
you're trying to raise funds and you're
trying to develop the product and
whatever you need to
you know as soon as you know that this
is what you're going to do that you're
planning on expanding to the us that is
the time to come and advise um with an
immigration firm like i said i i always
i think i make people um i upset people
sometimes and they're they're you know
they they're like well what do you mean
i don't have any options well you don't
have any options right now but you will
have an option and the next year if you
do
as i say lay the groundwork for your
process and it might not just be for you
it might be for multiple employees so as
early as possible to avoid those uh
pitfalls and delays in the process and
believe me there are plenty of them
along the way requests for evidence
background security checks and so on and
so forth
so as you're getting approached by new
companies do you find that
you know that
do you find that they're surprised by
the process that you know what's sort of
the reaction and the reception because
obviously you know when we're coming
from the tech world and we're building a
product we're ready
we we're ready for anything right we're
ready for things to move very quickly
sometimes hiring can take a day it can
also take months but but we're prepared
to move as quickly as possible
especially when we know we want
something done so there's this
dissonance now because sometimes
things aren't in our control especially
when it comes to immigration right
um so from my experience
most
entrepreneurs and founders are not
coming to me with zero knowledge they've
either spoken to their vcs
they've spoken to their colleagues
you know in in the high tech ecosystem
they're coming they're coming with some
kind of idea um there are of course a
couple of rumors you know that are
flying around i don't know who started
them but they some of them come with
this like you know um
you know someone told me this and that
so they have this like idea and then
it's like sort of got like some sort of
twist on it
so so they kind of have an idea and and
i'm glad that they do um and most of
them are not coming with like with zero
knowledge so that actually it helps in a
lot of ways because you know they can
rely on other people's experiences um
you know just for the general process of
course like we said before it's case by
case but they're getting a you know kind
of a some idea of of what to expect here
and i i try i try my hardest to
especially with the israelis they want
you know to know everything so i pull
out every possible question um that i've
that i've heard over and over and over
again and try and answer it for them in
advance um to minimize you know the well
that's a surprise you know that's a
surprise you know but again you're
dealing we're dealing with a field that
is is is uncertain you know and an
uncertain time so trying to manage those
expectations
tell me a little bit about where we're
headed and what you've been observing
with the trend what what can we expect
you know things changing
the process changing things becoming
easier harder throughout the years is
there a better a bigger understanding of
the globalized world and the need to be
dynamic or is it you know still very
much there's politics and then there's
business
um i think that the change of
administration has definitely um
helped matters it's definitely helped
matters um
i i don't want to say you know because
biden got in things are like just going
to be a walk in the park as i mentioned
it's never been a walk in the park and i
don't think it's ever going to be a walk
in a park um but uh over the past couple
of years there have been you know some
additions that were really helpful
especially to israelis uh the
introduction of the e-2 treaty investor
visa
was a big big big big big big huge deal
um
i don't think it's the greatest thing
for startups because it requires them to
maintain 50 percent uh israeli ownership
and that's difficult with when you're
getting like you know rounds from
foreign investors but it's it's
something which is awesome um uh there's
been a revival of um the new
international entrepreneur rule um which
helps it gets sort of like it's not a
visa but gives special special
permission to to enter and work for
certain um entrepreneurs who have gotten
invested investment from qualified
investors um that's i i think there was
a lot of excitement about that um but
just just so you know in 2020 there were
absolutely no adjudications for that and
i won't get into the ins and outs of it
because it's kind of it's kind of a
complex thing um but i think that um
certain changes need to be made to to
that rule in order to make it work um
and be more readily available for for um
for the general public basically i just
think that it's that the requirements
are are um
they're unreasonable and they're the
kind of things that make it impossible
to get it but again it's it's hope hope
is on the horizon um you know so someone
who's willing to like dip into those
waters you know we'll be happy to help
them out with so that's uh something
good for for tech companies
um very very cool
yeah and i think you know again these
folks that we're talking about here
tech companies i mean i have the the
privilege and honor to represent some of
the top companies and and you know in in
israel these are companies that like you
know they started i remember a few years
ago we sent um yodepo for example uh we
sent one person to the us and and look
where they are now you know amazing um
amazing like you know you can't it's
undeniable like you can't how could you
say that you know a company like that
hasn't contributed to the economy in the
us creating jobs for for hundreds and
hundreds of employees and that's just
one example of of many of many so i
think we're going in a good direction
yeah jennifer take me a little bit to
back your childhood what really
fascinated you as a kid you know before
law what really sparked your curiosity
um you know i was always interested in
international travel it was always um
something of interest to me and i think
that growing up in the united states we
as americans are a little bit um
ethnocentric you know because the united
states is such a big place you know so
you know i i got to travel a lot in the
united states but i think that when i
came to israel um
europe was was more accessible and
something that was a kind of a dream of
mine and thank god i got to to do this
was was to go to japan i was always
super interested in in the culture
in the food in the architecture and the
language just everything about japan so
in september 2019 i got to go for for
about 10 days and it was everything i
expected and more exceeded all
expectations and i hope i get to go
again now with all these you know with
all the restrictions but one day i hope
so too and what what really draws
inspiration for you
you know either on a day by day basis or
or an event that happened what really
inspires you
um
well i think one of the things that i
actually took up over the past year and
a half is is muay thai muay thai it's a
it's a mixed martial art um it's it's
thai kickboxing
so i go to this like and nobody like
believes that i do this because it's
just like wow jen's doing that but i go
to this hardcore
fight club called fight tlv okay it's a
kika ratsurima the waterfront and i
trained twice a week with with world
champion um
waitai kickboxer adirotem and i think
that um
aside from it requires for me a really
really high level of um
of physical and mental focus and i think
that
it sort of um
integrates very well with my law
practice it's kind of something that's
difficult to explain why that is but
it's just a certain
mental and physical connection that sort
of completes completes me as a human
being so it's been really a life changer
uh this muay thai and i'm honored to get
to do it with someone who's you know
who's a world champion incredible and
what are three words that you would use
to describe yourself
three words that i would use to describe
myself um independent definitely
independent
uh sensitive
and minimalist
less is more type of girl
i love it jennifer thank you very very
much for the time and for the energy and
the inspiration and i learned a lot and
i really want to thank you for it and
stay safe and stay healthy and i hope
that you get to go to japan sometime
soon
thank you so much michael really
appreciate it take care
thank you
okay bye
[Music]